hey good afternoon today we're talking
about hey these work here by the way so
if you want to cool off I'm not going to
stand there it's too noisy we're going
to talk about unusual infectious agents
these don't fit in anywhere but they are
really interesting and some of them not
might not even be viruses one of them
for sure is not a virus as you will see
but it's really really interesting and
the first one the first ones are called
viral phages okay and the first viral
phage to be discovered what's called
Sputnik and this was a viral phage of an
of Mimi virus which is another virus so
the name means virus eater phage
bacteriophage the phage in is Greek to
eat and so these viral phages as you
will see interfere they don't actually
eat other viruses but they interfere
with their multiplication hence the name
so there is a very large virus that we
talked about in this course called Mimi
virus the largest known virus with a 1.2
million base pair DNA genome this virus
Mimi virus infects amoeba and the
sputnik viral phage will only replicate
in amoeba that have been also infected
with the Mimi virus all right they will
not replicate on their own you can make
purified preparations of Sputnik if you
try to infect an amoeba sell it doesn't
replicate it has to be Co infecting with
the Mimi virus so it needs to replicate
the same style and in so doing it
reduces the yield of Mimi virus by
seventy percent so that's where the name
viral phage comes from and this is a
picture of what's going on here
now when Mimi viruses infect a me be
they replicate in the cytoplasm and they
set up these factories so MV f stands
for Mimi viral factory so don't even go
near the nucleus they encode everything
they need and they set up these big
cytoplasmic factories so this is a a
photograph electron micrograph of an
infected amoeba here is a viral factory
right here this dark staining material
and here are some Mimi virions here the
big ones these are mature Mimi very ons
very unusual they have this these long
projections coming out from the capsid
which you could just see there and this
is the factory where they're made and
you can see within the factory of this
they're smaller particles right there
those are the Sputnik viral phages so
they're actually multiplying right
within the factory set up by the Mimi
virus so they need gene products
produced by the Mimi virus so they
replicate right in that factory and they
interfere with the multiplication of
Mimi we don't know how and we don't know
what specific gene products are needed
if here you can see a mimi virus that
has actually sputnik's within it so for
some reason these have been encapsulated
not every particle of sputnik is
encapsulated in a mimi virus so this
doesn't appear to be obligatory but the
replication interferes with the proper
assembly of Mimi virus so here are some
examples of Mimi virions that are
morphologically aberrant so here for
example is one the normal Mimi virus
would have these nice projections here
this got layers and layers of what looks
like membranes piled up on one side and
here's see another one like this and
here's just another so these are effects
morphological aberrations of Mimi virus
caused by a co infection with Sputnik
all right so this was discovered a few
years ago and it might it wasn't clear
whether it was a general occurrence or
curiosity and now not too long ago just
a month or two ago a new
viral phage was discovered it's called
maimie virus and ma stands for maverick
and maverick is a kind of transposon DNA
transposon these these viral phages
appear to have homology with DNA
transposons this is a viral phage of a
virus that infects this little guy up on
the upper right this is cafeteria
renberg ensis this is a marine faygo
trophic flagellate so say eukaryotic
organism it's a protist it eats bacteria
so faygo trophic means it gets its
nutrition by phagocytosis bacteria the
people who discover this said we have to
call a cafeteria because it eats a lot
so they call it cafeteria renberg ansys
alright so lives in the oceans in fact
it may be the most abundant predator in
the oceans this guy right here so there
is a virus that infects it and this
virus is called ma virus so that I'm
sorry ma virus is a virus age of a virus
that infects these cafeteria guys now
this virus has this viral phage has been
discovered in a lake up in the Antarctic
Arctic the Arctic is on the North Pole
right Arctic the Arctic Circle organic
lake is all the way up as far as you can
go North without reaching the North Pole
there's a lake up there I'm sorry it's
Antarctica it's below I'm thinking of
another viral story up in the Arctic the
organic lake is in Antarctica it is a
hyper saline lake down there which is
frozen most of the year but covered with
ice but at certain times of the year
thaws out and it has microbial life
mainly in it and they found this viral
phage in
algae that are infected with a Phi cod
navarre so this is a separate story from
ma virus ma virus is a far-off age of a
giant virus that affects these guys the
organic like viral phage infects algae
that are infected with Phi cod no
viruses so if I cod no viruses are large
DNA viruses that infect algae and down
in these lakes in Antarctica they find
this viral phage they also find this
viral phage in other aquatic
environments as well now that we have a
few viral phage sequences you can start
saying where else do we find these they
found it in a hyper saline lagoon in the
ocean in near the Galapagos Island in
the Delaware Bay near New Jersey and
also a freshwater lake in Panama so
there have been sequencing projects at
all these sites and all they had to do
is go in mind the sequence information
and they found evidence for viral phages
and these viral phages both ma virus ma
virus and the organic lake viral phage
they all share a couple of genes with
the virus that they prey on and they
have other genes as well and they have
homology so you can search for those in
databases so one of the ideas for what
these are doing is that they may be
exchanging genes among viruses it may be
responsible for dean exchange in by
recombination and that encourages
diversity they may also have an impact
on the ecology of the ocean an example
of this was shown in the study of
Antarctic organic lake so they assume in
this study that the viral phage inhibits
the production of vicodin of viruses
they haven't actually done the
experiment but they assume it does just
like Sputnik inhibits Mimi virus and if
that's the case they did a modeling
study of the microbial community in this
lake this microbial community is mainly
algae and what happens in this lake when
there is Sun available which is not all
year the algae bloom and then the
viruses kill the algae and they release
carbon so they do a carbon cycle and
there are their alternate cycles of
blooming and virus killing down in the
lake now if you take the flower
page and you model that into the
equation for the oscillation of the of
the algae populations what you see is
that the viral phage lets the algae live
longer so they have more extensive
blooms and they're less acceptable to
killing by the fica da virus so this is
all modeling mathematical modeling but
the idea would be that these viral
phages could regulate the carbon cycles
especially in places like Antarctic when
you don't have Sun all the time and it's
very difficult to make an algal bloom
these viruses may have evolved to help
the algae grow so that's a very
interesting idea it may be that since we
find these in other aquatic environments
they're also involved in cycles there as
well because we know that viruses play
important roles in many of the cycles
for example the carbon cycle in the
ocean so these may be modulators of that
so they're very interesting so they're
relatively new and by this time next
year we'll have even more information on
them alright so that's viral phages yes
ah good question I mean maybe you have
virus ages in you maybe we all do why
not now that we have the sequence we can
look for signatures in all the databases
but I don't see why there wouldn't be
viral phages of other viruses as well
sure me so far they've only been
discovered in these big DNA viruses so
one idea is that maybe those are the
only ones that can sustain them but
we'll see yeah they have their own
genome so the viral phage has its own
genome and encode it's about 20 kb in
size and it has if it has some genes
that have high homology with the virus
okay and then a lot of the other genes
are unique so it's got its own genome
and it but it just can't replicate
without Co infecting a cell that also
have the other virus in it so this is
new this year we didn't have this in
last year's class so just since one year
all this has been learned okay so that's
a viral phage all right the rest of the
time we're going to talk about some
other very unusual agents and they
really
pants start to answer these questions
what is the minimum genome size needed
to sustain an infectious agent it's the
smallest you know and could an
infectious agent exist without any
genome so the agents will talk about are
going to address these two questions and
the ones will talk about our viroids
satellites and prions and these don't
fit into our taxonomic scheme for
viruses as you will see we call them sub
viral agents viroids are important
pathogens of plants agriculture y
extremely important as you will see some
satellites are associated with human
disease and prions cause very severe
dementia in people okay so those are the
three we will talk about thyroids
consists only of RNA there's no protein
in a viroid so you know we have been
talking in this course about how a
capsids job is to protect the genome but
these don't have a capsid they exist as
pure nucleic acid yet they're still able
to get from host to host without a
capsid they don't need receptors at all
I just checked the sub viral RNA
database this morning it's got 2883
sequences for viroids and related RNA
molecules so it went up about 13 from
there's a number at your handout is the
old number so it went up a bit since
last year so there it is the first
viroid was discovered in 1967 potato
spindle tuber viroid this is how we
abbreviate these VDS the viroid
abbreviation and it's the prototype for
all the viroids we're going to talk
about smallest known nucleic acid-based
agents 350 nucleotides in the case of PS
TVD some of these viroids don't do
anything they seem to infect and
replicating the host without any harm
others have second
comic consequences particularly in crop
plant suit if you have a crop you don't
want certain viroids infecting it so
viroids are just naked RNA and not only
are they naked but they don't encode any
proteins so really this is the minimal
genome and these can replicate as you
will see the RNA is small typically
circular single-stranded RNA highly
structured though when this is
introduced into plants these RNAs
replicate so the base used to be called
sub viral agents but now we realize
they're not viruses and they're not sub
viruses so we have classified them into
two families pops avoid viroid a pops pv
roi de okay is these replicating the
nucleus of the plant and ave a son v roi
de replicate in chloroplasts as you will
see okay so these are some of my
favorite viroids the kadang kadang
coconut viroid because the name is good
causes a lethal disease of coconut
plants if you ever see a palm tree like
this one where the leaves are brown
likely that it has a viroid infection
and this is affecting the yield of
coconuts so if you like pina coladas
it's not a good thing the hotplate
enviro is a viroid that affects the hop
plant with top use for beer yes so
you're happy because it doesn't do
anything to the plant and it's okay and
then there's the apple scar skin viroid
which just makes these cosmetic
alterations on the surface of your apple
you ever see an apple like this anyone
would you eat it if you saw this no
would you eat it
no it's not going to make you sick none
of these viroids infect people know so
you could eat it but in the supermarket
they're likely to be the ones left
behind because people think there's
something wrong with them but if you
ever see this it's fine you can go ahead
and eat it but if you get sick don't
call me because it's not the viroid okay
so they don't encode proteins or mrna no
capsid so protective coat no protein
it's just an RNA molecule circular
single-stranded smallest is 246
nucleotides the biggest 399 and the RNA
is extensively base paired as you will
see looks actually like a rod when you
look at these under am they don't look
like circles you look like rods and some
of the viroids have an activity called
ribozyme activity does everyone know
what a ribozyme is genuine don't so
ribozymes ourself cleaving RNAs
discovered some years ago and these are
essential for the replication of these
viroids as you will see so the ribozyme
is not in all viroids but it is in many
and we'll see what that does how do
these differ from viruses besides not
encoding any proteins or not having a
caps that they well the viroids are
parasites of the transcription machinery
as you will see all they have to do is
replicate their RNA genome and have to
make any proteins so they want the
transcription machinery whereas viruses
as we know all viruses or parasites of
the translation machinery no virus can
translate its messages on its own some
viruses can make messages right as we've
learned not all but some so the ones
that Kantor parasites of the
transcription machinery but in general
if you want to make a generalization all
viruses need to parasitize translation
but the viroids need to parasitize the
transcription machinery so here is a
picture of potato spindle tuber viroid
RNA as you see it's a circular RNA that
base pairs and folds into a rod so if
you do natured this it would be a circle
and it's been extensively studied as an
agricultural pathogen it has very
distinct regions it has left and right
and I which form a loop it has a region
that's been involved in pathogenesis if
you mutate this region if you change the
basis you influence the pathogenicity so
this viroid when put into potatoes makes
them unedible basically you can't sell
them so that's what we mean by
pathogenesis and then there's a central
conserved region as well so how do they
replicate here's what happens when the
viroid gets into a cell it is copied by
host RNA polymerase to the same host
enzyme that would make messenger RNA
from our DNA genome so it makes concat
immers which means it has multiple unit
lengths of the viroid within a longer
molecule and those concatenate are then
cleaved to form unit length viroids in
some cases by the ribozyme that's
actually encoded in the viroid RNA so
again the ribozyme is a sequence it's a
structured RNA that has the ability to
cleave itself all right so these are
embedded in many viroids so you can go
from having a concatenate replicated
state to individual viroid genomes these
were discovered by the way in 1981 and
resulted in Nobel Prizes to two
individuals and they may be relics of
the RNA world when there wasn't protein
around and this was one of the enzyme
activities that was present yes
right they use host RNA polymerase 2
they can code nothing of their own so
they can't you can't go wrong with a
viroid and saying as to have everything
given to it by the host so it's made by
host polymerase 2 and then the in some
rob viroids the ribozyme cleaves the cut
cat americ molecules so one of the
ribosomes that are present in viroids is
called the hammerhead ribozyme there are
different kinds of ribozymes this is an
autocatalytic south self cleaving RNA
it's a rather short sequence you can
transport it to almost any RNA and it
will cleave itself in a different
surrounding and as I said it uses this
ribozyme to cleave the concatenate
structures that are made during
replication now not all viroids use the
ribozyme not all of them have it and
then those that don't have it appear to
use nuclear enzymes to cleave there can
katamari instead of the ribosome so two
distinct evolutionary pathways so here's
a replication scheme of the members of
the pop poss pv roi de in a plant cell
now these RNAs get into cells most
likely by mechanical damage farm
machinery breaking the leaves or the
stems and that introduces the ribosome
because there's no vectors as we know
and there are no receptors needed the
rnase are brought into the nucleus
here's the ribozyme the circular blue
molecule that's the ribozyme host Paul
two copies it and makes concat immers so
now we have two units to genome units
here but they're actually longer now
this is labeled minus but plus and minus
really don't mean the same thing as they
do when we talk about messenger RNA
remember a messenger RNA we always
define as the plus strand but these
don't encode any proteins so there can't
be a plus and a minus it's just a
convention so that you can think about
how these replicate so I just don't want
you to think that the plus strand is a
messenger RNA so the initial concat
immers are copied again to make the plus
strand probably also by paul to
because the virus can't do it these are
imported into the nucleolus then where
they can Kadim are then cleaved by a
nuclear ler nuclease most likely so
there's no ribozyme in these particular
vo roids there then exported out of the
nucleus and then it can move to the next
cell the way material moves among plant
cells all right so the key is
everything's done by the host in this
case copying of the genome and the
cleavage and that's how these replicate
and that's it you don't need to make any
proteins you just take advantage of the
host so you can see that if if this is
possible then it evolves and that's what
happens in the case of ribozyme here's
the other family of I roads this is what
happens in the case of viroids in the
other family of vines these are the ones
that have hammerhead ribozymes that's
why we're drawing it like this again
these get into cells they go into the
chloroplast not the nucleus as in the
other case they go in the chloroplast
they are copied again by the cellular
RNA polymerase 2 and in this case the
concatenation of the viroid itself and
then these are copied again to form plus
strands which then get exported from the
chloroplast and spread from cell to cell
so you just need to have one viroid get
into us into a plant and once it's there
will spread systemically throughout the
whole plant from cell to cell alright so
this is different because you make
initially unit length genomes and then
you copy them again where is the other
scatta gee you making cat immers copy
them and then cut them again all done by
host RNA polymerase yeah
not all viroids not all viroids code for
ribozymes both strands and both strands
in this case it's on both strands yeah
because that you making Kadim ears and
they get cleaved and then you make
another concatenated they cleave
themselves also yeah so this is an
example of peach latent mosaic very and
just to show you where the ribosome
ribozyme sequences are located here's
the entire viroid you can see it's
extensively folded here are the cut
sites here and here for the two
different strands so here's the ribozyme
for the top strand and here's the
ribozyme for the bottom strand so just
to show you how these fold and the
cutting this folded RNA has catalytic
activity and it cuts either here or
right here and that allows the concat
immers to become individual genomes so
where did they come from so they've
probably been around before agriculture
in the 20th century we probably
introduce them into our crops ourselves
when we would be breeding modern crops
you start with wild plants and probably
some of the wild plants had viroids in
them and we transferred them to our
modern crops we do a lot of monoculture
we used extremely hybridized plants most
of the crops of different sorts in the
world all come from the same plants made
by the same companies they're
genetically identical and they have if
they have a viroid everyone gets the
viroid and these these plant lines are
global so viroids are global as well so
they're as i said now they're probably
transmitted by farm machinery they
somehow the if the viroid is in part of
a farmers crop and that farmer uses
mechanical equipment to plow that
mechanical equipment will transfer it to
another plan
how do they cause disease so some
viroids don't they just replicate in the
plant is fine but others do compromise
the plan they can ruin a whole crop
depending on the the planting question
but how can they cause disease without
encoding any proteins so we think this
all has to do with small interfering
RNAs so we believe that there are small
RNAs derived from each viroid RNA these
are produced by the silencing machinery
of the host the Argonaut proteins in all
of those and these RNAs probably silence
host genes and that causes the
pathogenicity in fact symptom
development correlates with the
production of these RNAs if you inhibit
their production you have less symptoms
and we think that some of these small
RNAs are actually located in that
pathogenicity determining region that I
showed you on an earlier viroid so as I
said before if you make it alterations
mutations in that region it affects the
pathogenicity of the viroid so we think
this contains the RNA sequences that
will eventually be chopped down to 21
nucleotide interfering rnas which will
then interfere with the host ok so the
symptoms are a consequence of
interfering but again not all viroids do
this only certain ones have done it's
not clear why that would be okay so
that's viroids that's that's our first
unusual class of infectious agents yes
how do they get in mechanical damage
because there's no insect vector there's
no receptor it's not brought in by a
bacterium or any sort so it's probably
mechanical damage somehow contaminates
farm equipment shovels tractors and
that's that's how it gets in yeah
alright the next unusual infectious
agent is the satellite and these are
again small rnas they're single stranded
there a bit bigger than the viroids 500
22 kb they lack genes that they need to
replicate
these guys do encode some proteins they
code one or two proteins but they don't
have all they need to replicate so they
depend on a helper virus they can only
replicate in cells which are also
infected by the helper virus so those
are satellites these viruses well these
satellites form particles on their own
and in in fact in most cases their
genomes the proteins that they encode
are part of the capsid either the whole
capsid or part of it so the replication
proteins the proteins they require from
the helper virus help them to replicate
they are not derived from the helper
virus they're completely unrelated they
have no homology with the helper they
just need functions provided by the
helper virus because they don't encode
enough proteins on their own so they're
different from viroids because they do
encode proteins but they're still
dependent on a host so the virus on a
virus the viroids needed the host to
replicate the satellites need another
virus most of the ones we know of are
also associated with plant viruses and
in a plant that's infected with a
satellite plus helper the disease is
different than if the plant were just
infected with the helper virus by itself
so the helper can replicate on its own
it doesn't need the satellite that this
the disease symptoms are distinct so
here are some examples of satellites of
bacteriophages and animal viruses so an
e.coli bacteria phage called p4 is a
satellite it requires p2 as a helper
that cannot replicate on its own doesn't
have enough proteins so it only will
replicate an e coli that that are also
infected with p2 the eukaryotic animal
viruses add no associated viruses these
are members of the parvo verde we've
talked about these a bit especially with
respect to DNA replication these require
add no virus or
herpes viruses as helpers so again they
are defective in the sense they don't
have enough genes to replicate they need
another helper virus but again they have
no homology with adenovirus or helper
nor does p for have homology with p2 you
could actually think that the viral
phages we talked about are like
satellites right because they form
distinct particles they have some genes
but not enough to replicate they do need
a helper virus the differences that I
can see is that they're much bigger than
the typical satellites which may not
mean anything and they also inhibit the
production of the helper now it may be
that there are some real satellites out
there that also inhibit the helper virus
I'm not aware of them at the moment but
maybe viral phages are in fact
satellites that have just evolved to be
bigger so we'll see so it could be that
at some point in the future we'll talk
about satellites and will include the
vaio phages in them okay this is an
example of a human satellite it's called
hepatitis delta virus now this is a sort
of hybrid between a viroid and a
satellite as you will see the helper
virus for Delta it's a satellite it
requires a helper is hepatitis B virus
so this has to come in fact the same
cell as Hep B in order to replicate as
you will see now though it used to be
that when this Delta was first
discovered it was thought that it made
hepatitis caused by hep be more serious
in people that doesn't seem to be the
case anymore there have been a lot more
epidemiological studies which the
results of which suggests that this is
not the case but it's out there and in
fact there are about 18 million people
globally who are infected with hepatitis
delta virus that's about five percent of
the 350 million carriers of hepatitis b
so a lot of people are infected with Hep
B globally and here's the distribution
of HEPA Delta globally for a time it was
also
invading Europe but the numbers in
Europe now seem to be declining and
prevalences is rising in the
asia-pacific region so 18 million people
have this satellite what is it it's a
one-point yes yep
yeah it does but it's not everywhere
there is happy but it can't be it cannot
be anywhere where there is no happy yes
absolutely nobody with hdv doesn't have
hep b you have to have hep beta so delta
carriers are a subset of those who have
hep b and that's 18 million out of the
350 million with hbv all right the
genome is a 1.7 kb RNA again it's
single-stranded it's circular like the
viroids and it folds upon itself to make
a rod-like structure so it's highly base
paired it also has a ribozyme like some
of the viroids do it encodes one protein
which is called the hepatitis delta
antigen and as we'll see this protein
encapsulate the genome where it
participates in the encapsidation forms
part of the coat of the virus and when
this virus comes out of a cell that's
infected with Hep B so again it has to
multiply in a head be infected cell it
acquires the coat the envelope proteins
of Hep B so the virus particle is the
Hep B surface antigens and the delta
antigen we have a picture of this to
make that clear alright so this is a
schematic of the genome of Delta again
it's a circular single-stranded RNA but
it's over seventy percent base paired so
it forms a rod-like structure and we
have a genome and an anti genome so this
is actually a better nomenclature rather
than plus/minus which we use well not we
but those people who study viroids call
them plus and minus but genome is an
anti genome is a bit better although
this satellite does encode an mrna ones
one mRNA which of course is produced
from the anti genome and it encodes
delta antigen so here's the open reading
frame and there are two versions of this
protein produced a large and a small
version and also has a self cleavage
guidance the red circle here so again
this is a ribozyme it can cleave itself
and that
is because this replicates by making cat
emerge just like the viroids do and
those are cut by the ribozyme so here's
a schematic of the replication just to
give you a sense for how this is
happening is very much like the viroids
except that a messenger RNA is made so
here's your incoming genome it's copied
by host polymerase 2 to make a
concatenate version here and then a
little bit more these red dots are the
ribozyme cleavage sites so this cleavage
here for example is giving you a an mRNA
which encodes for delta antigen the
replication continues you make longer
molecules you eventually get full length
plus strands out of these and then you
copy those again to make minus strands
so the point here is that an mRNA is
produced and there is also production of
long come cata murs which are resolved
by cleavage self cleavage at these
ribozyme positions so that gives you
genomes and anti genomes and this mRNA
which encodes for delta antigen so again
this is done by the host polymerase 2
because this is an RNA it has to be
copied by a host by an enzyme there's no
enzyme encoded in the genome that can
copy it so this is done by host poulter
so for a long time it wasn't understood
how this genome would be copied because
you know I have spoken many times in
this course about how viral rnas can't
be copied by host rnas right by host
polymerases so this is an exception the
Delta genome can be copied although it's
not a virus of course to satellite and
here is how we think the virion is put
together this is a hepatitis b virion
here on the right as an icosahedral caps
it in an envelope around it which has
the viral glycoproteins in it and here
is Delta virion it's smaller so the in
this picture the Delta G gnomish is in
the middle here it's coiled up as its
base paired rod like structure it's
coated with
small delta antigen along its length and
there's a large Delta at either end
which is believed to hold it to the
glycoprotein so these Delta particles
but out of the host cell and they
acquire the envelope of hepatitis B
virus so they have glycoproteins of Hep
B with a delta genome inside so these
can go on and in fact the same cells
that would be infected by hepatitis B
virus but if those cells are not
infected with heavy the Delta genome
will not make particles it will
replicate in that cell but it can't make
new particles so it's completely
dependent on Hep B for this envelope and
glycoproteins okay all right so that
takes care of our unusual agents with
genomes and that brings us to infectious
agents that don't have any genomes that
encode that consists just of proteins
and you may ask why are we talking about
this in a virologist and because they
don't have a genome so they're not
viruses they're just pure proteins their
infectious proteins and well I think
they're very interesting because they
have a transmission pattern which is
very virus-like but maybe more
importantly when these when the
existence of these agents was first
proposed by Stanley prisoner and who for
which he got the Nobel Prize eventually
no one would listen to him except the
virologist and so historically we have a
warm feeling in our heart for freons and
that's why they're in viral EG textbooks
nobody knows where else to put them but
i think they're fascinating so these are
pre ons and you have heard many of the
diseases caused by them mad cow disease
bovine spongiform encephalopathy
kreutzfeld Yakoub scrapie kuru chronic
wasting disease of elk and deer in fact
this is starting to spread in deer in
the US and they tell you if you go out
hunting deer you should watch out for
the spinal cord and brain stay away from
it because that's where these
infectious proteins reside because you
can be in you might be infected it
snowing there's no incidence of going
from a deer to a human yet but who knows
anyway so so prisoner got the Nobel
Prize for this we'll talk about what he
did so these are these proteins called
diseases that are called transmissible
spongiform encephalopathies all right so
pre ons are infectious agents without
genomes and these this name means a
fatal neurodegenerative disorder of
mammals just mammals we're talking about
here and thousands of humans come down
with this every year about 1% of these
cases arise by infection will talk about
how the others arise as well for example
by 2012 120 people had contracted
creutzfeldt-jakob disease by eating meat
from animals with BSE these were the mad
cows in England and we'll talk about
that in a little bit more detail so it's
a transmissible it can be transmissible
about 1% of the infections are
transmissible spongiform refers to the
pathology in the brain which will see
and encephalopathy means disease of the
brain so here are some of the TSE I'm
going to abbreviate that as TSE
transmissible spongiform encephalopathy
these are some of the diseases of
animals that we know of there's BSE
chronic wasting disease of deer elk and
moose exotic ungulate and sefa
encephalopathies feline spongiform
encephalopathy your cat can get mad cat
disease I suppose scrapy and sheep and
goats and transmissible mink
encephalopathy so that's an animals and
then in humans we have kreutzfeld Yakoub
fatal familial insomnia gerstmann
strauss ler syndrome kuru and variant
kreutzfeld yakko so variants CJ is the
disease that you get from eating
infected cow meat slightly different
from the original kreutzfeld yakko okay
so let's start with a little history
scrapie
is a disease that's been around for a
while it's been recognized in European
sheep for over 250 years it's the 1st
TSC that was recognised and the sheep
the disease gets its name for the fact
that infected sheep rubbed themselves or
scraped themselves on fences so the
farmers called it scraping and the sheep
get motor disturbances trembling and in
Canada the disease is called trombe lagu
moot all right it's not I didn't
pronounce it right yes important that's
that's what disease is quote paralysis
weight loss death within four to six
weeks and in the UK it's in one percent
of the sheep 1% of the sheep each year
get it so it's still around we haven't
been able to do anything about it so
that's a sheep with scrapie and they
besides the neurological symptoms they
rub themselves so they scrape all their
fur off and they have large patches of
skin showing hey doesn't look very happy
right yeah so he's going to die within
two months the farmers found the farmers
were doing the epidemiology here they
found that the animals that were in fact
it could transmit the infection to
another heard they could if they were
physically present they would transmit
the infection so they made the first
important epidemiological observation
and then in 1939 it was found that if
you took the brain of a sheep with
scrapie and you grounded up and you pass
it through a filter the infectivity goes
through filters that normally passes
only viruses which would have suggested
that it was a virus except that and
initially that's what it was thought to
be but then it was as it was studied
this infectivity or this agent was found
to have very unusual properties was
highly resistant to UV ionizing
radiation and formaldehyde things that
can activate viruses and then when
people were looking for nucleic acids
they didn't find any so they would take
these preparations that infected sheep
and they couldn't find any nucleic acid
and here's a result of an experiment
where
we're looking at the molecular weight of
nucleic acids of various agents and the
dose of radiation that's needed to
inactivate the genome so low doses to
high doses here so the viruses with big
genomes so herpes and vaccinia it
doesn't take a lot of radiation to
inactivate their genomes because I have
a big target this is all about target
size the bigger the target the easier
you are to hit as the genomes get
smaller you need more radiation to knock
out the infectivity so you can see here
polyoma the small DNA viruses some of
the small RNA viruses they're quite
resistant to radiation but look at the
scrapie agent here it's more resistant
to radiation than any known viral genome
so this is the first one of the first
clues that these were unusual that they
might not have nucleic acid because they
were more resistant to radiation as a
huge amount of radiation needed to
inactivate the agent than any other
known virus now the disease that are
caused by these agents remember we said
it was spongiform transmissible
encephalopathy so a spongiform means
that the infected brain is literally
full of sponge-like holes and this is
accompanied by psychomotor dysfunction
and the particular symptoms depend on
what part of the brain is infected each
disease that we talked about in that
slide of listing all the diseases has
its particular symptoms in pathology and
here's a spongiform pathology this is a
section of brain from an infected sheep
with scrapie and although I'm not
showing you a normal control you
shouldn't have all these holes in the in
this section so that's the spongiform
appearance caused by this agent and so
the symptoms are in part resulting from
this damage yes
could you make a vaccine against this
well as you will see it's one it's a
protein of yours that's causing this
disease it's not a foreign protein all
right well so we're going to get to that
now but it's your protein so you can't
immunize against yourself so you might
be able to if you had a vet if you could
induce somehow antibodies against the
specific confirmation of the protein
that is pathogenic but that's kind of
difficult so that's the problem okay so
all the tses the human and animals have
very similar histochemical abnormalities
their membrane plasma membrane defects
you get vacuole ization of various cell
types loss of neurons the spongy form
appearance which we should wish we just
saw and you get accumulation of this
protein glial fibrillary acidic protein
in clumps and finally they're all
characterized by amyloidosis and that is
formation of fibrils of amyloid protein
so whenever proteins accumulate in form
fibrils call it amyloid so this is one
of a number of diseases that do this and
along with the spongiform appearance
it's a characteristic marker so you can
detect the disease by injecting organ
homogenates from one species into
another and then what happens is that
you take a sheep with scrapy you can
make a brain extract inject it into
another animal and then you eventually
get symptoms of the disease difficulty
walking dementia and death but the
incubation period is very long can be
months to years so if you're studying
this you have to be very patient and
when you inject this these extracts into
animals it accumulates in very specific
places and then eventually gets into the
cns so as you'll see you can actually
acquire these tses by eating infected
meat so it can go from your intestine
eventually making its way to the cns
and as I said in the cns you have
astrocyte OSIS vacuole ization which is
the spongiform encephalopathy and loss
of neurons there is no there's no
antibody there's no immune response
there's no inflammation which you would
get early and infection with the virus
the cytokines being produced there's no
antibody produced there's no cellular
response because this as you will see is
our protein which is causing this
problem and that's why we don't get an
antibody response so this is difficult
because it makes it harder to detect it
you know with most infections we can use
antibodies to detect the infection but
you can't do that here so the problem is
that with most human tses you don't know
you have it until you have symptoms the
neurological symptoms and that it's too
late to do anything not that we can do
anything because they're all variably
fatal but at some point we theoretically
will have a way to ameliorate the
symptoms but we can't detect it right
now before clinical symptoms so we have
no diagnostic tools to determine who's
carrying the agent people are working
very hard at this and there are some
good leads but but not yet and of course
it's not treatable but as I said I think
someday we will have treatments in which
case we need diagnostics and it's a
hundred percent fatal so in 1967 after
all this these data were accumulating
Griffiths suggested that the agents of
tses were in fact protein so he looked
at all the data the ionization radiation
data the purification all of this and he
decided there must not be any nucleic
acid in these and then prisoner began
working on these he eventually purified
the protein that would transfer scrapie
from a sheep to another animal so he
started by making brain extracts from
scrapie sheep passing them on to other
animals and then he would purify the
proact and ask what part of the extract
is causing the disease they eventually
got it down to a single protein took a
long time because
the incubation time is up to a year for
this and he ended up calling it a prion
protein asia's and infectious particle
because he found that it was just a
single protein so he identified the
protein got some sequence and then he
could identify the gene its core its
encoded by the prion p gene so it's a
normal gene in us that encodes this
protein which under certain conditions
can become a transmissible agent of tses
and this gene is essential for the
pathogenesis if you don't have this gene
you will not get a TSE you can delete it
from mice and the mice are fine I don't
know if you can delete it from people
though I haven't done that but it
doesn't seem to be essential right so
maybe someday therapy will consist of
antagonizing the function of the protein
so our current view is that a prion is a
conformational I so form of a normal
protein so the normal protein we call
prpc prion protein C means cellular it's
normal normally on the outer surface of
neurons this protein is anchored by a
GPI anchor so that some normal function
the abnormal version we call an abnormal
come from ER if you take that abnormal
come from ER and put it into a host it
will cause the normal hosts prion
protein to be changed into a pathogenic
version so let's say you have sheep and
you purify the prion protein from them
that protein is in haven't what we call
an abnormal confirmar it's its structure
is different i'll show you what we think
it is in a moment you take that and put
it into a new sheep the abnormal protein
catalyzes the conversion of the sheep's
normal protein into an abnormal form
alright so that's what we mean the
abnormal conformer causes conversion of
normal prpc into the pathogenic form we
call that PRP SC so
see means scrapie so prion protein
cellular is the normal version and PRP
SC is the pathogenic version if you take
a normal version if you take PRP c and
inject it into someone it doesn't cause
disease but if you take PRP SC which you
can only get from infected animals and
inject that into another animal you get
you get a TSE so this PRP SC and an
animal with disease accumulates mainly
in the brain no matter whether you
ingest it or injected it gets to the
brain and accumulates there yes
you can't imagine that one abnormal can
cause the well we have some models
coming up for that at the triumph it
because that's a puzzle but you get a
lot of accumulation of the PRP SC
eventually that's why you have disease
because you have pathological levels so
it doesn't disease doesn't result from
just a few aberrant proteins you have a
lot of them right alright so these
aggregates accumulate in the brain they
make they make amyloid which are the
fibrils of protein and that's prion
protein you get these spongiform holes
and this protein this disease version
PRP SC is also protease resistant and
that was a important finding for
purifying it as you'll see so this is a
staining of a section of brain from an
animal with a TSE and the antibody used
to stain this is an antibody against
prion protein and these are these are
amyloid plaques so these contain fibrils
of prion protein and you can see they're
very discrete depositions of these in
the Blaine brains so that's what we mean
by amyloid plaques if you look at higher
magnifications you can see very the
highly fibrillar nature of these plaques
which is the accumulated prion protein
so normally your prion protein that you
make we all make a PRP c we know the
sequence of it it's GPI length and again
it's on the outer membrane of neurons if
you treat this with proteinase k which
is a kind of protease will completely
digest this protein PRP c is completely
sensitive but what prisoner found was if
you take the PRP SC from say sheep who
have scrapie and digest them with
proteinase k all it does is clip off the
n-terminus the rest of the protein is
highly resistant to proteinase k
digestion it's the same protein it's
exactly the same sequence yet somehow it
is folded in a way that it's resistant
to cleavage with proteinase k
okay so we know the structure of PRP c
and that's shown here this has been
solved by x-ray crystallography we don't
know the structure of the SC
confirmation is very difficult protein
to work with but the idea is that
somehow going from prpc to SC you have a
conformational change that makes it
resistant to protease digestion part of
the change involves making a lot of beta
sheets which is shown by this here the
protein has a high content of beta sheet
and that's probably part of the reason
why it's resistant so this shows that it
has conformational difference PRP SC is
very different from prpc yeah we know
the sequence of s it's the same as C
it's exactly the same protein but we
don't know the exact confirmation yeah
so that's what I want you to remember
that PRP c and s you have exactly the
same amino acid sequence but one causes
disease and the other doesn't so it must
be that it has to be something inherent
in this protein and probably this
conformational difference is part of it
so what causes the disease the key to
understanding what causes it is going to
be to understand what catalyzes this
transition we just don't know that yet
now in mice you can do very nice
genetics you can knock out the gene
encoding the prion protein you can knock
out the gene encoding PR NP the normal
cellular homolog these mice are fine as
I said and if you infect them with
crayons they are totally resistant to
infection they never develop tses so
that shows you that you need your own
copy of the prion gene in order to
develop the TSE and that's partly where
this idea that the pathogenic protein is
inducing your normal protein to change
into an aberrant form came from because
you need your prion gene in order to
develop the disease
so sheep spontaneously seemed to
generate come down with scrapy and there
they may it may arise as a genetic
mutation in them so there may be
spontaneous single amino acid changes in
the prion protein which make it miss
fold and become pathogenic so those are
rare mutations or you can acquire these
tses by infection so she can get it from
each other so that's what those are two
ways that these appear by infection or
by a rare mutation that causes the
protein to miss fold so the ideal proof
of the pre and hypothesis would be to
make conformational e altered PRP SC and
vitro and then in fact an animal and
people are working on that it's not
quite possible yet to do that but at
some point it will be done but there's a
lot of very strong evidence for this
entire hypothesis so how does a normal
protein make an abnormal version of a
protein in you I'm sorry how does the
scrapie protein the abnormal protein
cause conformational change in your
normal protein so there there are many
hypotheses these are just two here's one
on top where here's our normal PRP c and
this prpc theoretically can change into
the pathogenic confirmation here you see
that in this model it's not happening
there's no alteration between the two
states so in you you just have the
cellular confirmation but if you
encounter some abnormal protein if you
eat infected meat for example then that
abnormal protein can catalyze the
confirmation of your normal protein to
make abnormal ones and then those can go
on and catalyze the conversion of even
more so then you can see that this cycle
would amplify itself and eventually your
normal protein lots of your normal
protein would be converted that's the
refolding model so the idea is that the
scrapie version of your protein causes
the normal cellular version to refold
the seating model there is a there is
some equilibrium between the normal and
the pathogenic forms of the protein so
if you have some abnormal protein
forming it would very very slowly
convert to multimeric forms and then as
you add more abnormal protein these
would eventually form the amyloid fibers
leading two plaques so this says that
there is extremely slow conversion and
in some of us that leads to disease it's
very rare and that occurs by this miss
folding yes well this happens to be a
brain specific protein it's
theoretically that could happen
somewhere else sure and maybe there are
diseases that we don't know about yeah
sure there's nothing brain specific
about the mechanism now okay there is a
very nice story about human TSE which is
actually the 1st TSC to be discovered
it's called kuru it's a fatal TSE in the
for people of New Guinea with a 30-year
incubation period an American
epidemiologist Carlton guide you sec
studied this disease and he found that
it largely attacks met at women and
children and that's because when people
die and the four people they're the ones
who eat the brain of the deceased person
the men don't get to eat the brain just
the women and kids and they develop crew
so he studied this and he said you're
having kuru because of this so you have
to stop the cannibalism and they did and
the disease is now gone so this was the
first human tsc known and it came about
it was perpetuated in this people
because of cannibalism how it was
introduced well probably years ago
someone had a sporadic version of the
disease where they just converted to the
pathogenic form by maybe a mutation or
some other environmental insult and
someone ate that person's brain when
they died and that started the epidemic
in this tribe
so human tses there can be infectious or
transmissible like kuru you can have
spread of these diseases by
transplantation of infected corneas by
giving people hormones that are
contaminated by transfusions this has
been documented to occur among people of
course vse you get by feeding ground up
infected animals to cattle and that
ended up causing a variant type of
disease in humans called variant CJD
which is you get by eating BSE beef so
basically forced cannibalism spreads BSE
if we had an epidemic of BSC in the UK
there's a form of cattle cannibalism and
this is because we we fed the cows
chopped up other animals so they got
homogenized high-protein diet the cows
normally don't eat meat right there out
there eating grass but farmers want them
to grow quicker so they give them
protein and in the UK they were giving
them ground-up carcasses of other
animals and some of those animals had
died of scrapie without anyone knowing
it so the cows got a form of a TSE
called BSE or malc out mad cow disease a
lot of similar symptoms dementia ataxia
spongiform encephalopathy so this was
recognized in the UK they stopped
feeding this rendered stuff to the cows
and they stopped getting BSE but a lot
of people ate BSE contaminated beef and
they in turn got a variant TSE called
variant CJD so this is a map of the
epidemic in the UK the onset of bovine
mad cow disease BSC in about nineteen
eighty-seven you can see this is when
the first cases were discovered and then
they banned the use of this ground up
feed and cows but it was too late
there's a very long incubation period so
you can see the disease peaked a number
of years later and then eventually it
went away but then you had an overlap of
an epidemic in people these are very
people with variant CJD they acquire
UTSC by eating
emanated beef and this seems to be over
now there are no more cases in the UK so
it's a form of cannibalism really yes
well this is related to how the meat is
the meal is prepared for the cows so
they used to this they used to like
recover the spinal cord by blowing it
out with high-pressure air or water and
they said you can't do that anymore
because that just contaminates it with
pre ons so they banned that kind of
process to limit it and they also
instituted some processing measures that
would inactivate the pre ons so this is
over but whenever there's a BSE positive
cow somewhere in the world the meat from
that country is banned yes
a vertical transmission of a prion I
don't know of any there may be but I'm
not aware of it you know of any I don't
know
from mother to child nobody okay so that
there's a kind of TSE that's infectious
we've been talking a lot about there's
also sporadic and this is around a
million people worldwide typically 50 to
70 years of age sixty-five percent of
all the TSE s is this sporadic form and
here it appears without any warning it
doesn't seem to be any relation to
eating any infected meat you have normal
genes your PRP genes are normal and you
can transmit it to others so if you give
a transfusion or something or you give
blood or some other product that's not
checked properly you can and you can
transfer the infection because now you
have pathogenic protein in you and as I
said that's probably how kuru was
established in New Guinea person got
sporadic CJ and then they ate the brain
and that established the infection so
that's sporadic there's also familial
which is a genetic disease you have a
mutation in your gene that predisposes
the protein to miss folding and you
develop the disease but if you donate
organs or corneas or blood products and
you don't know you have this then you
can infect others and that's how some of
the transmissions have occurred via
these kinds of products from people with
a familiar form of a disease so we have
three kinds we have an infectious a
familial and sporadic so the familial is
genetic the sporadic just occurs and we
don't understand the conditions that
cause transfer the transmission we don't
understand the conditions that cause the
conversion of a normal protein to the
pathogenic one in these cases so what's
happening here is we have a normal
cellular protein if you eat infected
meat you get some pathogenic protein
that converts your normal protein into
the infectious pathogenic form you may
have a familial mutation that
predisposes you to miss folding or you
may have some spontaneous miss folding
that occurs this is the sporadic form so
three different ways that this
altered protein can arise there is a
speed yes
so in the sporadic form there's no
mutation it's a normal protein and
somehow it just spur it just begins to
miss fold and that causes the disease
and then you can transmit it because a
Miss folded protein no matter how it's
made is it potentially infectious okay
the only ones with a change in the
protein are the familial forms which
have a change that predisposes it to
miss folding without any infection or
anything else okay so there is the good
news is there is a species barrier it's
not easy to go from one species to
another so if you put diseased brain
from one animal to another you don't
always get disease for some reason it's
inefficient most of the time to get the
best transmission you have to do it in
the same species and a nice example of
how to overcome this if you make
transgenic mice that make the bovine
protein you can then infect mice with
the bro the bovine tree on so normally
if you take mad cow extracts and put
them into mice the mice don't get sick
but if you give the mice a transgene
that produces the bovine protein then
the mice will become infected so the
barrier to transmission is in the
sequence of the protein but apparently
you can go from cows to people that's
not a problem but you know from say a
deer to people we don't know if that can
happen or not so maybe in some cases
we're lucky these prions have a broad
host means they they appear to affect
many different kinds of meat-eating
mammals so some pre ons can overcome the
host range and that's why BSC is a
concern because it does cow BSC can
infect people there are interestingly
strains now of the scrapie protein
there's no genetic information but it
can vary and their strains that have
different incubation times brain
pathologies electrophoretically oh
strange and these all seem to have a
different protein conformation so these
are not mutations simply slightly
different foldings cause the proteins to
act in different ways and these can
evolve amazingly these can evolve in
so you can actually take a prion from an
infected animal and put it in cells in
culture and the prion will multiply in
those cells and you can pass the prion
from cell to cell as if it were a virus
so you can make cell adapted populations
of pre ons you can make brain adapted
pre ons you can use drugs like suena
swainson een to inhibit the production
of prion xin these cell cultures and
then you can select for variant proteins
that are resistant to the drug again
this is not a sequence change you're
selecting for slightly differently
folded proteins so the point I want to
make here is that pre ons are like
Darwinian can evolve in a Darwinian way
they're subject to mutation not really
mutation is not based in sequence but
conformation and you can selectively
amplify them it's really amazing yes are
there others yes absolutely East is full
of them my last slide is it's got that
so this is just to show you that this is
increasing in deer elk and moose is the
only tsc affecting free-ranging wildlife
you can see here the areas where we're
finding these even in New York State
Virginia as well and so again as I said
this is a problem for hunters because
they have to be really careful so this
slide sort of summarizes how all of this
may have arisen I really like this the
blue is naturally occurring tse and the
red is artificially so probably all of
this began in sheep we can blame the
sheep because they can't defend
themselves it spread to wild animals
contact with sheep or eating sheep for
example it spread to other animals like
mink mink I guess bother sheep sometimes
they could get infected could get into
cows on the same farm from sheep and
then of course the cows led to BSE the
cows probably led to infections of other
species by feed product transmission and
also into cats so all of these tses
probably originated from
we got our variant CJ from cows and
these a lot of these people who had
variant CJ probably transmitted it to
others by transplants of various sorts
and then there were probably some
sporadic origins which are natural and
humans from which I at regenexx spread
also occurred so as I said pre ons in
the food supply is a problem because of
the experience with BSE and a lot of
work is being done to try and protect it
from this we're developing diagnostic
tests and screening for drugs that block
accumulation of crayons because at some
point some war is going to get into the
food chain and it's going to be a
problem now the last thing I want you to
know is that not all prions cause
disease they have been identified in
other microbes as well and they don't
cause disease they create protein-based
memories and they they are believed to
allow organisms to switch between
phenotypic states so you have a cellular
prion and a pathogenic prion but imagine
in yeast you have two forms of a protein
with two very different functions and
this may help the yeast for example to
adapt to stressful environments so in
yeast well many Benny prion like
proteins have I been identified and
these are proteins which can change
confirmation they don't change sequence
but they change confirmation and then
they have a new function associated with
that change and hear all the native
proteins in yeast and then in the prion
state this is what they're called and
they do different things so for example
in mammals we've been talking about how
this conformational change leads to a
disease but in yeast these changes allow
the yeast to use different sources of
material to metabolize altered carbon
source utilization the indiscriminate
utilization of nitrogen so they're
beneficial and so probably the vast
majority of prions that exists are good
and it happens to be this one causes a
neurological disease
yes yes it goes back and forth in these
yeast cases now that in humans it
doesn't seem to happen
way
I I suppose theoretically it could but I
don't it's not been shown
you